cruzan constantemente el tapón del
darién la selva que separa a colombia de
panamá en un intento por llegar a
estados unidos este año cerca de 19 mil
niños emprendieron esta peligrosa
travesía según el fondo de las naciones
unidas para la infancia una cifra que
triplica la cantidad de menores de los
últimos cinco años combinados y que
representa una crisis humanitaria se
consideran medidas adicionales como la
creación de un puente humanitario que
facilite el tránsito de niños niñas
adolescentes mujeres gestantes y mujeres
lactantes sin que tengan que poner su
vida e integridad al enfrentar los
peligros del paso por esta zona
selvática esta parte del viaje es
especialmente peligrosa debido a la
presencia de traficantes de personas a
los robos y a las agresiones sexuales
algo que parece no detener a los
migrantes ya que entre enero y
septiembre de este año el número de
personas que llegaron a panamá triplicó
a las del mismo período en 2016 cuando
se registró la última cifra récord
además uno de cada cinco migrantes son
niños y señora estaba embarazada y yo
fui para allá yo pasé yo pasé de la
serva y de ahí a mí sin el aita voto en
la selva casi murió mi señora ya pasemos
como cuatro días en la selva sin agua
sin comida sin nada más cosa que no
quería hablar de eso por ejemplo muchas
muchas personas muertas fueron a la
selva llovió como como seis personas
mueren al frente de mí en la en el río
peligros por los que muchos mueren en el
intento de llegar al norte del
continente según datos de unicef al
menos cinco niños fueron encontrados sin
vida en la selva este 2021 mientras que
algunos consiguieron llegar a panamá sin
sus padres